if I could cut this in half I would give
the other half to my daughter
methrepleton
we did this together kiddo Kate Winslet
in tears dedicating her latest trophy to
daughter Mia and obviously I you know
I'm a mom we did this together kiddo the
actress takes the stage after winning
the bafta TV Awards Kate Winslet
[Applause]
[Music]
guaranteed to be the only one of the
night to cry you are not judged you are
not crazy well I am so am I not that's
Kate acting with Mia in I am Ruth the
mother-daughter project Squad mom the
best leading actress on her oh God I
can't see bafta just in case speech and
now I can't see what it says but lucky
for acceptance speech and speed comes
straight from the heart if i if I could
cut this in half I would give the other
half to my daughter Mirth rippleton
we did this together kiddo
[Applause]
where's my phone it's what's making you
ill there were days when it was Agony
for her to dig as deeply as she did into
very frightening emotional territory
sometimes and it took my breath away I
wanted to keep Mia as happy as I could
yeah Kate and Mia looked happy before
Showtime
with the twinning moment on the red
carpet
after the ceremony Kate's look-alike
daughter can't hide her excitement over
mom's new award we did this together
kiddo and get this it's a full circle
moment for Kate who gushed to E.T about
being a mom at the baftas in 2001.
mother it's fantastic motherhood is
great just months after welcoming Mia
with ex-husband Jim threepleton nothing
compares to it nothing in the world
flash forward to 2023 kids also mob to
two sons Joe and Bear
what's the matter nothing
[Music]
as Mia follows in Mom's footsteps she's
22 years old
the same age Kate was when Titanic
sailed into box office history literally
the only similarity between Titanic and
Avatar is that that there is some water
in it it seems Ewa has turned her back
on you
Chosen One
fun fact Kate's kids were behind her
Avatar reunion with director James
Cameron they told her you have to do it
you should stay back all right did they
love average before you join the
franchise so so yes they loved Avatar
and they were very excited for me to be
a part of this and we're excited over
Kate's support for Mia as she takes up
the family business if I could cut this
in half I would give the other half to
my daughter Mirth replton
we did this together kiddo
[Music]